my whole life is a m night shyamalan
tale all right well
every week do you like the twilight zone
do you like the twilight zone you know
what
this is not my show so start the way you
start no weed this is it
so i have questions for you um and i was
you know
i've known you for a long time and i've
worked with you several times
on some television programs and whatnot
and i've never really analyzed your body
because to me when i look at you you're
like um
you're around around yeah around
you're around like you know i mean i i
know that you're around but i don't
analyze you
yeah it's just like you don't really
know i'm beginning to think you're a
little person
because i looked at your body just now i
go everything's just so small
and cute and compact right are you a
little person
i'm not legally a little person i'm
five feet tall like shakira is shakira
five feet tall
411. shakira's 411 yeah i could snap her
she is so successful she like
she writes all her stuff shakira is
really a queen she's great
at 4 11 she is a queen and not a little
person so you're not a little person and
so um but you have you could you go to
the like little people like stores like
is there like a little
teeth what's your shoe size it's a five
it's very small it's very
pretty big for five foot tall no most
people my height are bigger than that my
best friend she's five two she has a
five
she wears kids kid sizes kids three may
i give you a compliment
yeah okay i've never seen your profile
before
oh my gosh okay i'm so uncomfortable no
no no i'm being real
okay i missed your profile before number
one
you would look really good on a penny
why a penny and not a good nose good
chin yeah yeah because your profile
yeah because i don't have a good chin
yeah so you'd look good on a penny
in fact i would cl i'd be if you were on
a penny
i would be a penny collector are you
like is bobby hitting them
no no that's not going to be hitting
first of all can i always say this there
is absolutely nothing sexual about you
when i look at you my dick goes inside
my body out of my butthole
right it's like it's so non-sexual it's
like
um nah no
pass no thank you i do want to know
how well before me of course how you
what's your
flirt tactic do you have one esther i do
we should we should we should cover that
but first and foremost you guys welcome
to bloodbath oh hi
welcome to episode five annie our dear
dear annie is suffering from severe
cluster headaches
so we have a version of her which is
which which means okay well i'm sorry
babe
it's a favor it's a favor so i don't
know why you would tackle favorites
welcome
my lover the king of my life the captain
of my ship mr bobby lee hello
hello so what were you gonna ask me what
are we talking about how do you do
tactics how do you flirt
this is how i do it well first of all
you know um i'm the type of guy
that's like like if you had like
you're at a restaurant right and you
have like you know they're
you know sometimes they have the the
favorites this these are our hit you
know sometimes our menu will
these are what people love right so we
you know and then i'm like
popular items i'm the i'm the menu that
you asked do you have that other
special menu like the animal style and
in and out the secret menu
yeah a secret menu right and so i'm very
specific i'm like
duck puree you know i mean
some weird bobby me too your secret menu
i'm the same category right so i'm that
second so when i walk into a bar
or a place to meet the ladies right i
already know
that 99.9 of them i'm just
not you know i mean on the menu yes yes
okay
okay i'm the secret one right so the
difficult part
is they're not on the menu or i'm not on
the i'm not on their menu
okay everyone's on mine yeah except for
me
except for except for little people yeah
i mean although little people are sexy
and i don't i'm not
gonna get cancer i almost i i would very
gladly have sex with a little person in
fact i almost did
you [ __ ] me oh that's true yeah that
does count yeah
it does count [ __ ] me so um and when
esther and i were vaccine we did agree
that i was going to sew my
and lips to her do a human centipede to
celebrate i hope my fiance does not
hear that because they can jump in on
the line he can be third behind me
yeah he's very scared that i'm not
straight
[Laughter]
i i i open with something like so then
once i find the girl
right that i am on their menu i'll say
something
stupid like hey after this party or
you know i mean after this you want to
wrestle
like something funny yeah if they don't
jive with that yeah
i'm out right hey do you play chess
or something like that and they're like
yeah i know how i got a chessboard you
want to play
yeah you're so sweet go ahead
how do you find the girl who you know
you're on her menu
because they're looking at me oh no
but not you know this i get this a lot
right if i walk into a restaurant and
nobody knows who i am this is what
people do they go
well they'll do like a double like you
know i mean oh i saw it
i got to see it again but make a face so
it's like this it's like
and they got to send the message like no
yeah no they will never
you know yeah yeah right but the girls
that like me go like this they go
ah i know the girls are like that like
you yeah
they're not okay in the head what are
they like one time we were in portland
and this girl
um very cute blonde girl she was like i
bought us
nipple tassels do you want to have
dinner afterwards like they're just very
forward with him
not she didn't know that i was his
girlfriend so like to be fair like that
was not her fault
but she just came in and she was like i
bought nipple tassels do you want to try
them on me
and i was like i was at the san jose
improv yeah i don't know if i told you
this
and there was just a girl in the green
room yeah a blonde girl uh-huh
and she's like she's breathing heavy
yeah that's
generally what likes me
i feel like you're describing me
yeah yeah so she's just like she got
because it's hard to get up there
yeah you you know you have to go through
a mouth guard with her
is she wearing diapers you have to go
through three
did she forget her inhaler at home
you're gonna go through three
security situations to get to that green
room three checks
so she kind of ethan hunter her way out
there right impressive so she's
i don't know if it's because it took her
a long time to figure out how to get up
there or
she's just a heavy breather but she's
just like
i was such a big fan of years and you
know i just you know i'm not like the
regular
uh fans or people that bought the
tickets you know i'm a super fan
and i just needed to talk to you and
meet you right and i was with nick
youssef or something like that
and then the uh manager came in he goes
out
to her i go well she seems nice you know
i mean
out so she she leaves
security takes her she he goes she's
here every weekend
so i thought because she did that the
steve brown was izzy yeah so i called
steve
as izzy and i go dude that blonde show
he's
me too that's so funny she's the heavy
breather i go yeah
were you sad when you found out that's
what i can get
one time we were at san francisco at um
what was a small club there lottery
street punchline punchline
and there was this i guess she was a
friend an acquaintance of his
a couple years ago but again she didn't
know that i was his girlfriend
she just thought i was a rando in the
green room and she was like you take
this picture of me and him and then
shoo away and she's shooting the [ __ ]
away
so like do you know what i did i took
the picture and i shoot away
i was like yeah of course no problem
because i wanted her to feel so
embarrassed after he when i leave their
room and saying oh yeah i gotta get back
to my girlfriend now
that is a you know what you're [ __ ] a
sneaky [ __ ] i am a sneaky boy that is
like that's what she just explained is
like and i know because i'm a sneaky
[ __ ] that's like
sick it is sick it's very it's a
different level of satisfaction when
someone looks so stupid
rather than confronting them confronting
them they can just say sorry
being a sneaky [ __ ] then they feel so
stupid
so stupid how do you flirt um
or do you not need to because you're so
pretty oh yeah so why do i ask
questions i'm really bad i don't do like
sexual undertones i don't do any of that
she's hot
shut up i've had to try a lot you don't
have to try
lady what the [ __ ] i have been rejected
you're not like us
all right this is a dif that's why
you're we're here and you're there
not sure i think esther esther if i was
into [ __ ]
you would be on my secret menu why
yuck let me see this okay
the reason why esther and i have to do
stand-up and all this other [ __ ]
right it's cause we're [ __ ] ugly [ __ ]
nothing we're [ __ ] no things that should
be our podcast when we start one
the [ __ ] nothings all right we we
right when we wake up we hear this song
follow the yellow background i mean
we hear like things you don't mean that
you don't hear well
in your head is a wry song or something
cool you know what i mean
we're off to see the wizard that's our
song now listen
wait i want to know how she flirts yeah
how do you flirt break it down
let's reenact it i'm in a bar okay i'm
both on each other's secret menu you're
right wait i just want the secret menu
reference i've never felt so seen
yeah you get it i get it i'm not i'm not
for everyone but for
when you find the right people it works
okay so
no the let's act it out okay all right
so i'm in a bar
hey i'm bobby hi master
hey come on what are you what are you
doing here are you alone
uh um i guess so yeah i was with my
friends
but they are cooler than me so they're
talking to people whatever uh
yeah can i buy a drink oh um
okay so i don't drink but like that
doesn't mean i don't want you to buy me
a drink
i you this is this is what you're going
to hear
that's my dick going down why wow why
oh you're right you're right you're
right you're right she's playing
coincidence
all right all right all right you're
right i still have a hard lesbian hard
on for you
no but can i i feel like my tactic is
better explained
than shown all right explain it first
and then show it
okay i feel like that was really working
for me it was work it was working so
explain it first and then we'll go back
in
okay so i learned this on
accident but basically i for me
when you're in my when you're in my part
of the menu
you act like you're not interested but
you're you're just trying to make a
friend
so i i will treat the guy that i want to
hit on the same way i would treat like a
cool person that i'm trying to make
friends with you're just super normal
and friendly
and like that's it that's it in your
head i just want this person to be my
friend i just want this person to
be my friend nothing romantic nothing
sexual and then that has worked for me
somebody told me once that you like your
[ __ ] oh my god
wait where's the shame in that i do too
no but like she's the only guy who holds
no no like
it's out there no no
[Music]
also shame on that person for [ __ ] no
[ __ ] and telling it's not
he has it wrong if you let me just say
this let's go back to a restaurant
restaurant analogy okay if i eat an
average hot dog
at a hot dog stand right i'm gonna be
like i'm not gonna tell anybody about it
right the only way i could tell somebody
to go to this hot dog stand
is if this hot dog was the best hot dog
i've ever eaten that's how people
explain eating her ass
oh no i feel like that's the title of my
bio pig yeah yeah
why eating an average hot dog for eight
years
that's my final pick your favorite [ __ ]
you yeah
why won't he eat your ass um he's just
that's just not
she's a hot girl that's like i know even
if i were to spread it even if it was
nicely
soaked and scrubbed really last night
you know okay uh you know what's gonna
be
your flirt sex
last night right she goes like a kid he
will like bop you what will you and he
thinks that i'm supposed to know what it
is
this is not what i'm doing you go bop i
don't do pop
astra this is what i did last night you
know that machine
the massage machine that you guys got
yeah yeah you all got one yeah
right she goes dude this on my leg all
right so i go she had her legs out
and her underwear so she's kind of you
know i really wanted a massage i know
i'm using the machine right but while
i'm doing it
i'm no but see he wasn't even kissing my
leg like gina darling said he was
kissing the bed
no i was kissing your ass you were you
weren't you were like kissing the sheets
no i was kissing your ass and you're
like you know i was kissing your ass and
you're like that
does i don't want that right now i was
i'm sore i need a real massage
there's a time for that but see you're
not being very truthful
oftentimes you do bop and wet willy but
last night i didn't and don't
anyway esther so you're what's the
signal that you give your partner what's
the correct way
to signal your what to signal a partner
just speak in general
that sex is impending that something is
gonna is about to happen
like texts like hey wanna have sex meet
in the bedroom
oh that's good could i ask you about
your [ __ ] yes
so you are you are obsessed with this
whole narrative
for years you've brought this up
because i've heard about his legend for
years you bring up this narrative that
you are just attached to
by just so tightly that yes guys in the
past have
have been drawn towards eating my ass
the guys i've dated
i i moved out here to l.a i was fresh
from
skokie illinois nobody had ever even
tried to do that so i was very surprised
when i started dating
and guys just went straight for it and i
was like wow like
why yeah it was very new to me it was
exotic
and then it just became something like
it was like a talking point like wow
no it was explained to me i'm sorry i
like that okay shame again shame on that
person for
details it's not just one person no i
want to hear this several people
i'm angry for you i know i know several
people all right
if it was just one i would just let it
go as hearsay okay
okay all right she
she threatens litigation by the way yeah
i would be and i'm not naming names
so that so there's no legal matter here
okay
but several folks said that
i know bobby you don't like eating ass
i go i don't like it they go but that
you would and i'm like that always
struck me they did not say
yes yeah so that's what they did
that's a mythical asset what does your
[ __ ] look like
that's what so that for me it's always
been what's down there
msg msg i wanna know
yeah yeah is it a different color or
flavor what is it
it's just somebody was hyped on me and
they were just bragging about me
and yeah that's what it was that is a
crazy thing to say
yeah i'd be proud of it all buttholes
are the same
apparently not they're not apparently
not turns out there are
levels to this game there's levels of so
um
back to me real quick um
and everyone wondering why is bobby in
on this podcast right now and i and i
have to say to be honest
um i had to strike a deal it took a lot
of begging it took a lot of
begging at first i was like [ __ ] no get
that lady
get that lady out here yeah and you're
like she has cluster clusters and i go
no no but anyway i go in order for me to
do this i get
five days of unarrested uninterrupted
you saw things that unerect
unerect an uninterrupted video game time
all right no massages no massages
because every night i had to [ __ ]
massage her it drives me crazy it's just
the feet and
and for ten no it's not for 10 minutes
babe and you and also it was [ __ ]
about it is
that you if i don't do a good job you
let me know
i give you a grade all right so grading
system
she'll go like that i'll do 45 minutes
man that wasn't your best i'm like
[ __ ] you i always say things like wow
you've changed you've changed yeah
so but the third thing is that i wanted
hollywood pie
oh so it's that time order me a pizza
okay
i'm just shocked and in awe over the
negotiation
system you guys have in play there is no
leverage
in my life that i could ever use to get
a favor out of dave give us an example
of what you really wanted and what you
didn't get
i i could say like please this time
clean blank or like oh help me
help me with this rewrite or whatever it
is i'm working on please please please
please please like i need it right now
he'd just be i'll be like i'll do
anything and he just like there's
nothing you can do
there's and because he won't trade um
tasks for sexual favors which i hate
because that's what i used to do
that's how i got all my history homework
done in high school
he won't he's like i think that's like
he like draws a line there
you know he doesn't want to feel like
i'm doing something we'll figure it out
what if you frame it like what if you
frame it like this dave help me with
this rewrite
and i'll give you the best [ __ ] oh my
god
you've ever had in your life i think
that he would help you
have you ever used that esther the best
have you ever used the word best [ __ ]
no job
the best i i really don't like
overselling myself
so there's a lot of pressure that's a
lot of that would be like yeah i don't
know
because you're doing things that you've
never done before you look you're going
to feel ridiculous
i don't like i didn't i'm not up to
speed on
like keeping it hot in the bedroom like
i'm 33 like i feel like that was like a
young girl's game
and i'm just kind of like that is what
it is beach to completion is a young
girls game
i have tmj my jaws are old and tired
or you know what you could do help me
with this rewrite and just pull out your
[ __ ]
he'd be like uh he'll go [ __ ] hog
wild you know what's really sad about
all of this
is that i feel as though if i had
offered that to you
to do but i don't you'd be like you
don't have her [ __ ]
yeah that's from what i hear right
through the rumor mill
it's [ __ ] great a [ __ ] right here
baby
support for bloodbath is brought to you
by manscaped
who is the best in below the waist
grooming and hygiene
and ladies listen up manscaped offers
precision engineered tools for you and
your man's jewels manscaped is trusted
by over 2 million men worldwide so why
not trust it for your man too
manscaped has created the best ball hair
trimmer
very very important to sustain this
relationship i have with bobby lee
really
absolutely we have an exclusive offer
for our listeners 20
off plus free shipping with the code
bloodbath at manscaped.com
the lawnmower 3.0 is their third
generation trimmer that features a
cutting-edge
ceramic blade to make sure that the man
in your life
reduces grooming accidents i have to say
i feel like manscaped has really
they did it they figured it out it works
no nicks no cuts just no complaints
no airplane or any more i
love bobby's smooth balls it makes me
feel as though he respects me more as a
woman and cares about my well-being
so guys and ladies if you want to feel
smooth and sleek
and chic hand it over to him and say
babe this is for you
you guys get 20 off and free shipping
with the code bloodbath
manscaped.com that's 20 off with free
shipping at manscaped.com and use code
bloodbath
unlock your confidence and always use
the right tools for the job with
manscaped
and if you've been thinking about
manscaped now's the time to support the
bloodbath babes and use our code
bloodbath
to find something that dave loves
more than sex do you know that because i
know his top five
things yeah what are the hollywood pie
that he loves
okay so great great example follow-up
question
why can't he just have that every day uh
he's not allowed i
i i make a scene really oh wow
it's so bad for me i'm gonna get a heart
attack it's a deep dish pizza
and then because none jules and i don't
eat it with him so now he has just i eat
the whole thing
pizza for himself and so i i get on his
ass about
um did you order did you order it i
haven't because we're recording what do
you know you need to order now so that
when i'm done with this i can get it
well here's george kimmel for that job
so yeah so the five things that dave
would like
so what are the things sex beyond sex uh
i guess like
uninterrupted reading time
oh my god is there something that he
does for you that
he doesn't really necessarily like but
he but you know what sucks about that is
that it makes me think that when he's
reading you interrupt him all the time
he's like i'm reading you know
why would you interrupt a man when he's
reading what he's doing all the time all
right
well he okay so he loves to sleep mm-hmm
as we know he has sleep apnea so he has
sleep issues he needs a lot of sleep
but i'd let him sleep all day well then
that's not a thing that's not a thing
you can use it
sometimes that you don't allow him to do
but you're gonna allow him to do it
i allow him to do everything he wants in
kovald because i
how about this you did threaten to
crash his all-boys weekend in palm
springs that's true
and then he begged you esther you cannot
and then well he got really firm he said
if you
show up to the boys weekend in palm
springs no questions asked our
relationship is over
okay well that's something to use as a
bargaining chip look dave i will
never threaten to crash any future
boys weekend if you do this you know
what i'm thinking because he's been
playing golf a lot lately is like
i'll just start to act annoyed when he's
going to play golf
that's it yeah that's it that's the
smart one and then so it's like uh
okay like no it's fine it's fine so then
i'll i'll use golf as like a tool a
lever a piece of leverage and
you can go play golf yeah you just got
to take some things back
yes i've been given too much that's what
it is yeah
wow that's smart mm-hmm i've been giving
too much
what you have been given too much
there's only no i can not give you
that kind of room over me oh what are
you talking about well she's just
getting healthy yeah you get to live
like a king for the next five days
i get to [ __ ] just sit and die a
miserable woman in a dark hole somewhere
in this house well why do you care when
he's playing video games because he does
it for 20 hours a day and he will blow
off
any responsibility and he will throw all
his trash all over the house he'll let
his toenails grow out
it's he becomes a gargoyle it's a an
addiction
it's a true addiction esther he won't it
like
basically this whole space here would be
a dumpster if we i let him just run free
with a video game play
you know one time i came into this
garage and there was a like a couple
cups sitting out that had been there for
a while and there was a growth
and a stench yeah and kalei was like oh
bobby was in here last night
it took me two days to air out this
space and you still came in and smelt it
that's how
that's that's what we're looking at here
that's what i get that's what you get
how do you guys keep sex
fresh this many years in
we're the wrong way but i don't think
that's true because i think you guys are
very sexual
and you have role plays no we have we
okay well i don't wanna let's dive in
when we do
have sex it's literally the best it
great it is porn worthy yeah it's porn
worthy but it's like we should do it
more often we should be doing it
everybody feels that way but the quality
is good it's good
i would rather have what we have than
having to just like
you know put out every single day and
have like vanilla sex
it's a big production yeah it's also you
know especially during the pandemic i
have to say that it's a difficult thing
to navigate because
kaleido and i aren't only only lovers
we're also
best friends she's my only real friend
right
and she's the only one that i trust
implicitly
and she is now up there in terms of my
world
right she's in that sphere of my mom
and my brother who are the only family
members are alive
you know when you have i've never been
in a relationship this
relationship this long and um so it's
hard to navigate we also
you know there is something about not
seeing somebody for a while and that
mystery right
like if i was going on the road right
out of town a lot more often
and there was a little bit more space
maybe there would be a little bit more
mystery but but
because of this pandemic you know i've
seen this lady 24 7
every day for months and months and
months and months you know what i'm in
and you know you get on people's nerves
we get on each other's nerves yeah
don't you and dave aren't you and dave
like that yeah we spend we're in
separate rooms a lot separate wings
we yeah i i get frustrated when couples
have like say like oh yeah we have sex
three times a week and i'm just oliver
hudson
drives me crazy he's always bragging
about oh yeah
i i had sex with my wife you know at the
you know on
on the beach or whatever we went to
santa monica one night and
during the morning we just had sex on
the beach that's like and they've been
together forever and it's like
some people are like that i just don't
find that to be realistic or relatable
to like i don't know i think it's not
relatable for me at all
i think i'm really intrigued by you guys
though because you guys do intense role
play and i've only
dabbled in it and whenever i do i really
like it but i have a hard time
getting back into it because i'm like
nervous and well basically
is dave good tell well i want you to
tell bobby exactly
what well the only character you play in
real yeah i want to know
neighborhood girl oh what is that so
it's like you show up
and you're like oh hey like i was locked
out of my house like oh
you know it's kind of like i'm like a
scammer i'm like hey like
i need a place to stay how old are you
in this in this scenario like my around
my age i'm
oh would you say neighborhood girl yeah
neighborhood girl does sound
young but well you you and i do age
stuff
i'm the young guy you're the older one
and i
never had sex before and his brandon
thanks for thank you so this feels so
good thank you so much for doing this
i'm a cougar
yeah she's a cougar and yeah and then
she'll and then she'll just
i can see her just just like digging
mike
and i'm like oh this is this is
different
also one time i don't know if we said
this but um i just sucked my penis like
you with some other guy
like it's some other actor that you like
and you sucked it 10 times better
she was like doing [ __ ] like you know i
mean i was like whoa whoa whoa
if you say benicio i was just gonna say
that i will honestly i will go balls
deep baby
yeah ball's deep i heard he is pretty
dirty though
i love that's exactly why no like i
heard from a girl
probably hearsay again but um he is
spitter
and spits in the in the hole ew i mean
this is a lube you cannot possibly turn
my spit is fine but to go
that means you're getting a like a chunk
of your lungs oh they're long yeah yeah
your
maybe i'm doing it wrong i didn't i
wasn't there when it happened
what is what what role plays do you
prefer
anybody but himself
if he shows up as bobby liam out
he's got to come in ready as somebody
else
you know it's funny that you say that
it's funny that you say that and i'm
chuckling in the inside
i have to say but um
you know i look at photos of us when we
were younger
together like eight years ago and um
we were younger we looked different we
acted differently we acted differently
we look different
and you know it's an inevitable thing
that people change
some people grow apart you know but i
think we've changed
with each other i think so too yeah but
the problem with us
is that like
is that we both be both when we first
met let's let's let's agree that there
was a high level of toxicity probably
just because i was very like in the
middle of
you know didn't couldn't figure out my
life yet same with you he was in a
really low point in his career there was
a high level of toxicity
oh i was dead what do you mean
my career was dead man there's i
remember like one time
he for five days he was like i hope i
get that job i hope i get that job and
it wasn't even a paid job it was just
like
um being part of this sketch that oh
yeah yeah so
i was at the comedy store once i felt
something and this english guy was like
hello i go hi because
i just saw you on set on on stage and
i'm doing a sketch show i go really what
is it
tell me more he's like yeah just do one
and he just was shooting some random
thing like just
for youtube yeah some youtube thing and
i was just like
so excited about it like that's where i
was
in my career i just thought it was like
i was dying
i kind of remember you in that era you
and i i remember you
like kind of alluding to that a lot and
i was always confused by it
but it was weird it was like um at one
point in my career i wasn't felt like i
was on fire
and then at one point i just really
thought i was just never gonna get back
and you could feel it in my road numbers
you could feel it
in terms of the type of auditions i was
getting
you know i mean like it is it does feel
like
back then if you were down you
it felt like you really were going to
stay down but it seems like now
maybe this is just like me like being in
the business for
like a longer time it feels like it we
really can go down and up and down and
up again
right but i i love i love a good picture
upper
really it's my thing like my best friend
always says this i'm the number one
number two i am the best at being
someone's number two
like i just there is nothing more
gratifying
to me than seeing like raw talent and
making sure
that i'm writing their coattails but i'm
making sure that they get there
number one you're both right so what you
just said right there
is is that yeah you're right what i
didn't know at the time
where in everyone's career remember
there was a time where neil patrick
harris
was in everything he was in everything
and then not so much
right i just feel like everyone's career
does that right in life in any
occupation that you have right you have
highs and lows
but i didn't know that you know you just
assumed that this is going to be my
reality forever
right so during that time i needed
somebody
to show me that it can go back up again
right
and then that's what was vital about you
yeah yeah and i have just no experience
in the industry at all
i just watched now she's [ __ ] miss
hollywood oh my gosh it's very chris
jenner to like find a broken man
and then make him a star is that maybe
time for a banana break
your first banana break i love that i've
had that as before but not everybody
will come in babe
ah thank you raspberries
did you did you see how he just what are
you doing
throated that banana he's like he's like
a two bite banana guy
oh my god bobby do you remember
when we used to go out to dinner after a
comedy store with
with people what what what
we went to ihop and do parts you would
always take us all out
buy us food i know because i you know
it's so funny i learned something back
then
since i've been in la that i don't
really like you
and let's be honest you know what you
are it's banana break can i be honest
during the banana break right i really
don't like you
i know yeah i'm not being real all right
there's something about you that just
really irritates me you know i mean
i don't know what it is but but i have
to say this
what i do and i do something very
shallow and what i do is i go
i look at what's underneath me
in terms of people that are coming up
and i kind of in my own way
hand pick who i think has a shot
right so even though i don't like you
i've always thought that you had a shot
that's a projection though i really
truly think that you see so much of
yourself in esther too much
way too much and he hates he has a
self-loathing issue you and i are very
sensitive in the same
ways yeah and you've called me about
like issues you've had
you're i don't know you know this
this this job i don't i don't know if
i'm going to get it or not
yeah i mean or you gave me such good
advice you meant i can't even believe
the nice things you've done for me that
i don't think you would ever do for me
today
but back in the day you were so nice to
me you met me at coffee bean
and like helped me talk out this really
big decision whether or not to do this
reality tv pilot
and he was just like you're an idiot he
was like there's two categories
on the air and off the air be on the air
and you can finish my
drill out and i always like that was
such a generous
yeah i mean i had you know i've had and
vice versa i've had
a lot of generosity from older people
right that's helped me like
i told you when i was living out of my
truck at the company i was living out of
my truck
are you what is with these people so i
lived out of my truck
you know you could get a job i know i
know
like no you don't have to i mean
nowadays because the [ __ ] economy is
so bad but
but there was a time when i first moved
to la i don't know where i was going to
stay
but i just knew that i was evicted from
my place in san diego so there was a
time where i slept in the truck
so what and i didn't have any money and
i remember one day
i get a knock on my window it's about
noon i was sleeping
and it was jimmy schubert and shoes goes
um
hey kid you hungry and i go
yeah i said it like that and
brandon let me buy you a sandwich so we
walked down the street there was a
sandwich
there's no longer there he brought me
like this nice sandwich
for lunch so but i remember i'll always
remember that i will always remember
him buying me that sandwich so i always
kind of looked at little things like
that
right and i i learned from it so that
you know
i could help people you know if if they
have the ability i think jimmy always
thought that i was funny
you know i mean i think that if i wasn't
funny that he might not i don't know you
know what i mean but
kalila did you know that today's episode
is sponsored by bluechew
i'm so excited say it with me blue chew
blue chew blue chew is making waves and
bringing more confidence to the bedroom
by offering
chewable tablets that can help men get
stronger and longer lasting
e-r-e-c-t-i erases she won't say it but
i will
erections blue chew is a unique online
service that delivers the same active
ingredients as viagra and cialis
but in chewable form and at a fraction
of a cost
their tablets help men achieve harder
stronger
erections to combat all forms of ed
erectile dysfunction it happens to the
best of us guys no shame in that
but head on over to blue chew what i
love about it is that the process is
simple sign up at bluechew.com consult
with one of their licensed medical
providers and once you're approved
you'll receive your prescription within
days
the best part is it's all done online i
love this kind of service everything is
online it's discreet it's professional
they just make things really easy and
the best easiest part is that it's
chewable
and you have to swallow a dang annoying
pill blue chews licensed medical
providers work with you to find the
right ingredient and strength for your
prescription because
everybody's different and the tablets
are made in the usa
and they prepare and ship direct so it's
cheaper than a pharmacy
it's very very it's i think it's very
forward-thinking
so you guys if you could benefit from
extra confidence when it's time to
perform
visit bluetooth.com for more details and
important safety information
and we've got a special deal for our
listeners try blue chew
free when you use our promo code bath
girls at checkout just pay five dollars
for shipping that's bluechew.com with
promo code bathgirls to receive your
first
month free and we thank blue chew for
sponsoring this podcast
it's free you pay five dollars for
shipping why wouldn't you do it
did you see the woody element i did how
many episodes
are there three i didn't see the third
one you don't
yeah okay the it's not like you've
missed that much
like you kind of you know what's up yeah
but the first two
were bangers do you i shouldn't say
bangers
do you think when it comes to
here's my question because do you think
there's any chance
that it's that he didn't do it i'm just
gonna tell you
i don't it seems very obvious to me but
then there's a lot of people that say
there's a lot
like this this show is very one-sided
but i'm just curious what you guys think
as a child well-documented
as a child that has been um
on the other side of sexual assault i
just know how
sinister it can be and how family
members can defend you and not defend
you
and even the people that you love like
don't come to your defense like i've
i felt very unsafe as a child so
there is nothing to be had and nothing
to be gained from saying somebody hurt
me
so unequivocally a thousand percent i
believe that that's what went down
there's nothing to be gained from saying
someone did that to you
yeah the the naysayers are saying like
oh well mia farrow has all these
there's other of her kids that say that
she abused them and that
she coached dylan and oh that she was
complicit
that mia farrow this is not what i
believe but like that she
coached dylan into saying that she's
like the scorned woman and she's so
pissed so she like is doing this to turn
on him
does that make sense well i mean i mean
that could make sense because he
he did you know i do i mean this is
not in question he's with sunni yeah so
that's not in question
right yeah she is much younger than him
yeah she was groomed she was groomed
right so that that stuff is obvious i
don't think anyone can
right so i don't know what it's like you
know
if i was dating if i had you know i mean
let's say i had a son
that i raised from like guatemala
let's just say because i like the word
guatemala
right great country right and i look
good let's call him
his name i have a son named poto and i
got him at
12 from guatemala right he's grant
soccer he makes coffee really good
and um so um and i meet a girl online
right who's my age
all of a sudden i find that i see photos
of
porto right with this dick out and she's
stuck in his dick right and all that
stuff
the rage that i would feel imagine the
rage right
so i ca in that situation maybe i could
make up some scandalous lie to hurt this
person
yeah but why would you need to involve
the kid like an innocent
child that's a mother that loves her
children why would i need to drag my
child through this it's really hard for
me to believe that
that that a woman would do that okay
that's fine but there's no record of i
understand maltreating i understand i
understand that but what i'm saying is
that it's not hard to believe it is hard
for me to be for you to believe it right
it's not hard for me to revenge is not a
hard concept for me to understand i just
don't understand why she would have
chosen that route to take revenge when
there's multiple other ways
so here's my take on the woody allen
thing okay
when i was growing up i saw him
and i went he was the only person really
in film
that was that famous that i could relate
to because he was ugly
that not only was he ugly i
i also like you know like i saw dana
gould's one of his very
early showtime specials when i was in
high school
and it was all about like his
insecurities
and self-loathing and neurosis right and
anybody that portrayed all that kind of
stuff right
is somebody i could glum on to because
it's like
that's what i felt right i liked people
that were like you know very insecure
and and paranoid and neurotic juice
she's coming with it right right this
week jews
you're right i'm lucky to have someone
like kaleila because i feel
impish and neurotic and ugly and all
that kind of stuff right
so it's hard for me to believe why once
he had mia pharaoh or any woman that
would want to [ __ ] that
right that he would resort to any of
this other [ __ ] because
is a [ __ ] sickness it's an a literal
like
a disease like a mental illness it's a
mental illness yeah where our attention
should be
what did the little girl say at that age
you're right i'm not no
you're right i believe he did it and as
an adult she's still saying it
this was her experience we don't we
don't invalidate her experience we say
oh okay that's
and i'm saying this from obviously like
a very biased standpoint because
when i told my parents that somebody had
hurt me
my family's reaction was to not protect
me but was to cover it up
yeah when i told my dad i was molested
by a guy with down syndrome at rehab
he laughed in the in the counseling
session
it is funny
[Laughter]
right yeah it sucks he to me i agree
like he
he clearly did it why would this be it
but it's so weird that there's so
many arguments for that he didn't do it
like a lot of people bring up like well
he was even mentioning this in an
interview on like that they were showing
an old interview because he's like why
would i just do it all of a sudden now
i've had opportunity like this this idea
that this is the only one so it's not
true
which does suck like it sucks that
women have to almost like wait for
others so that they can come forward
because one voice isn't enough
and it does make me wonder like yeah
maybe this was his only the only time
this was when he was close to a little
girl this was his shot
like i see that here's my real point
though
and this is something that um
you know i always say has tom hanks
ever been accused of anything weird
sexually eating babies by q anon i think
yeah aside from the q and [ __ ] yeah why
do you love to give that credit
yeah well you know yeah yeah throwing it
up tom hanks never ate a baby okay he
hasn't eaten
right right so he's the most wholesome
yeah right
guy out there i think one of them right
he just seems like a nice guy
all right and there's never been any
kind of accusations do you know why
there aren't any no he didn't do
anything yeah
right there's just certain guys out
there that like you know
um you know leon dicaprio
right leonardo dicaprio right he's known
to go
dictate 18 19 20 year old model models
and stuff like he's always on a boat
somewhere in
you know florence italy or whatever it
might be it's florence is there water
there
okay good so i don't want to sound like
an idiot right and
it's not he's not going to argue that
right it's he knows
right it's not as anything has he ever
been accused of
having sex with a 12 year old why
because he's never
did it he never did it right my point is
is that
i think that certain you know rumors are
there yeah
because right because there's some
scandalous they don't typically just
come out of nowhere here is his age
breakdown
leonardo dicaprio refuses to date a
woman over 25. so this is a
graph in relation to his age yeah
and that's the ages so at 24 he dated
18. at 44
he dates 21. um there's
some uptick some the oldest he'll go is
25.
the oldest he's ever gone is 25. one of
those girls on that chart
went to high school with me oh really
aaron heatherton
oh wow did you know we're friends no but
we i
she's very lovely but bobby i do you
would break that chart
bobby yeah i think you're right like i i
that was something i another thing i
learned when i moved to la like
if there's rumors there usually
didn't just come out of nowhere were
there smoke there's fire yeah i i'm
curious to see is is is
his reputation damaged enough for him
never to make movies again
i would i would think i would think too
um also it's like take your millions and
you know live a good life nobody wants
to do that no one wants to do
that's only you know who doesn't want to
do that a true narcissist it's weird i
know i
i literally i look at people who have
like three million dollars and i'm like
just
move to wichita and have a great time
let's give example carlos mancia
he has millions of dollars and my
brother one time told me he goes
well gives a [ __ ] man he's got millions
he doesn't have to do it anymore
right but tell that to carlos you can't
because
the whole point is you know right now i
don't think i
don't have enough money to retire for
the rest of my life right
but you know i'm still
you know i'm getting jobs you know and i
i ca i can't imagine a life without
you know me getting these new jobs and
opportunities and seeing how far i can
go
right it's like if one day they said
your voice is shot
you can't podcast anymore you can't do
stand-up you can't act you can't do any
of it
right but you have millions of dollars
good you know so
there you go i don't think i would be
happy i'd just be like
what am i gonna do i would i'd be so
happy i'd be like oh my god i get to
rest i get to try something new in my
life
build a farm garden you [ __ ] you
[ __ ] you consider it earlier [ __ ] you
you would not
i know you you would be so [ __ ]
miserable you [ __ ] lying lady
you're a lying lady be honest with me i
see both sides
i don't know if you had 30 million
dollars and then somebody said to me
right
somebody said to me somebody said to you
listen you have
you you can no longer talk esther what
about this
today i give you 30 million dollars
esther but you have to retire from doing
stand-up
acting any any stints in the future
you're done i think just legal live in
obscurity i would be
so stupid not to take that deal okay and
then i'll
i'm gonna get the call eight years later
she's in [ __ ] wichita
right and she's gonna turn on the tv and
see somebody
that she's in competition with that's a
big tv star yeah but not still
not that person doesn't have 30 million
it doesn't matter she's going to sit on
her couch right and she's going to be
she's going to weigh 300 pounds by now
just just blob this ester blob right
right and then she's gonna lift over one
slab right look dave's gonna be there
sleeping it's sleep and apnea under one
of her [ __ ] fat flops
right and you're gonna go you're gonna
go dave
he's sleeping right and you're going to
call me and go
i just saw someone so on the thing and
you would [ __ ] complain
and you'd be so [ __ ] miserable i okay
i think there's truth to that i think
i understand that i would like to think
and follow along with coloko's plan
and i think you can do the work i really
can i say something i'm gonna i'm gonna
flex for a moment
i am so good
at improvement i have been i started
anti-depressants
i see a therapist i believe
that i could take my millions my my
kalila millions and build out a life
where it could work uh-huh i agree yes
sir
there's no that i'm not gonna get to 30
million
on this path i would great amazing if if
i get to
any of a small amount of that why
i think you're one job away from that
that's negative one more episode of
bloodbath away
you got the poison in you yeah you're a
poison you want to
be celebrated i'm not as sick as you
whoa i'm not that yep okay i want to
i want to say something to you all right
all right
and let's just be real okay
i've heard your phone calls to me all
right
right because i was there listening
right and the kind of [ __ ] i'm not gonna
get specific right
but the kind of [ __ ] right right lets me
it's evidence and it's also like you
know you know
analytical you know stats stats
right i'm looking at the stats and the
data right
and the data tells me right that she
would hang herself from that wichita
house
oh no that's what the data tells me okay
so i don't know what you're trying to do
now right
what i'm going to say to you is that i
think that you're i've always said this
about you
that you are so unique
right you really are i in comedy i don't
know anyone like you
right in terms of your persona the way
you deliver your jokes
the way you act all that stuff right
you're your own
thing which is great okay thanks bobby
but you're all [ __ ] up on the inside
you really are so [ __ ] up on the
inside yeah
you ha yeah okay fair
the journey what's the difference
between well you have me now
and me having 30 million it would not be
the difference well here's what i like
money doesn't fix or change right this
here's what i like about the both of you
is that you're not willing to come you
really do love what you're doing
it means that there is no amount of
money that you can get paid
to um basically turn your back on your
dreams well i did say yes to the money
you did and then but you got on you were
then
he unconvinced you it is the wrong
choice to say yes to the money
is wrong because it is life is not about
the end point it's about the journey and
that's that's a [ __ ] hard lesson that
i'm learning
relearning every day because i'm was
always the first kid in class to turn in
my test i was rushed rush rush get
everything done just get to the point
of being done with your work but it's
about the journey
esther and i there is certain there is a
fix
that you get george have you felt the
fix a little bit i feel
i'm just happy where i am i like always
be growing you know
the journey is the destination i'm lucky
that i wasn't
born with a silver spoon in my mouth
because that gives you a much different
like view of success
yeah i came from like farmer parents so
i'm happy where i am
but always trying to get better yeah i
feel similarly like i didn't come from
money so
the fact that i have i'm able to make a
little i'm like
oh my god i'm amazing i feel great but i
want that doesn't mean i don't want more
and i do i i i get what you're saying
i know the fix i want the fix i want
it's a drug but i'm also trying
to shy away from
that try to detox yes i'm trying to
to have both i'm trying to be healthy
about it
because you can't be this babe it's god
there's the high high
about low lows is a is i don't want that
anymore
i don't want it either i'm not saying
that i want it okay
all i'm saying is is that i feel like
i'm in a
you know kind of an even keel right now
in my life right
in fact i'm turning down certain jobs
because this is too much on my plate can
you pass them my way
no you know and there's just certain
things that um
i've made some really adult choices in
the last couple of months that was like
startling to me even really oh yeah
adult choices
well just cut this out but i turned down
well really why i think this is worth
talking about wait why did you turn a
movie down
because it was um well i i yelled a
whole lot but she did too
but um but it made sense to me it was
like it was there was like an
asian accent right and it was a cool
movie it's a
it's a vampire movie i could say that
yeah right probably a blockbuster kind
of maybe a blockbuster kind of a movie
with a real action director and he
he zoomed to me right we zoomed each
other and he was trying to convince me
to the movie
but at the end of the day it's like and
the money was going to be good
it's going to be you know um
i i might have taken if i didn't have
this other movie i had doing but
no you wouldn't have okay i refuse i
honestly bobby 2021
you uh have made such you have blazed
the path for a lot of asian
american people in the industry the fact
that you would regress
and do a film with an accent would break
my heart yeah here
here here's i did the last time i did an
accent was i was in the movie the
dictator with sasha baron khan yeah
and i did an accident oh yeah what a
long time ago my point though is that i
did feel
guilt yeah for doing the accent and then
i remember going to john chow
and saying hey i don't ever see you do
asian ex
he goes i refuse i'll never do it ah
good for him yeah i mean and i just
don't think that we should
wow right but he goes if you do want
bobby
i won't judge you i get it you're
comedian and a lot of these roles
you know you're a character and all that
stuff you know me just says
i i won't do it anyway we should talk
about
esther what's the thing you wanted to
talk about foods that we've never tried
yeah i are there any okay
are there any common everyday snacks
that you've just actually never tried
i'm sure there are a lot because i'm
just not a big candy person
so i eat there aren't there are very few
chips i've never tried but in terms of
chocolates and snacks and candies
i've never so okay i've never tried
cheetos and i've never really told
anyone that before because i'm a big
snack person
why why haven't you tried it they look
scary to me i don't like that bright
orange
fake cheese like cheese whiz kind of i
don't like that scary to me it's i think
they look
disgusting but not even hot cheetos no
the darker orange no
yeah they do look like um they're shaped
like also
meteor it's yucky or like something that
you would find
on the surface of mars but i love
doritos i love
ruffle i eat chips i'm a chip queen but
i'm just so it's not like i think i'm
better than chips you should try cheetos
wait hang on one second so you're is it
the cheesiness you don't like or just
the shape and the color
it's just the concept of like the it's
all of it
i just want to say something to you
right now esther
what that in terms of what's
inside something the the dorito is the
same
you know it's just a different shape
shape no yeah yeah that's not the same
so we have cheetos
we have cheetos right here are
[Music]
they have to be the flaming hot ones are
the best are they spicy yeah very spicy
very healthy spicy food i like to have
some too i'm hungry
yeah pass it i love cheetos
okay helen i want to know what your
expectations are in terms of taste
oh i think it's gonna be spicy and okay
i i think
i think right close your eyes okay take
one out and i think you'll be
delighted delightfully surprised
seated mmm what a crunch
i like it they're spicy though huh
i like it a lot i told you they're
really good
how great are they i love it are right
earlier cheetos good too
yeah oh my god regular cheetos are not
as good as the flamin hot to me
maybe can i have some it's a little bit
oh it's good
it's so good i know it's so [ __ ] good
you missed out it's really spicy though
is that extra flamin hot yeah
yeah yeah george
[Music]
how would you do that here no why would
you do that well
esther your your spice um tolerance is
low you think
this is not spicy at all to me yeah baby
don't [ __ ] your filipino ways
yeah jalapenos don't have spicy foods
what are you talking about i'll eat them
i just breathe have you tried funyuns
maybe years ago have you tried combos
years ago combos are my favorite combos
are great they give me a little tummy
tummy
um what else is good well
bobby thanks for making me i'm gonna say
thanks for being here but
listen i you know listen you know um
i know annie's a coward well
don't slander i'm not slamming she's in
pain but cowardly
in pain poor annie i love you she's on
her way to pick up her oxygen tank right
now
oh that's how much in pain she is i love
her
i have sympathy okay but um i'm very
happy to fill in any time no not anytime
there needs to be a contract
but um thank you for having me on mm-hmm
thanks for being here bobby thank you
it's been a pleasure to be your friend
for a decade
we've known that that long dude yes
probably longer
he barely knows me no i love you what
are you talking about
and uh i'll see you soon kalila because
we live together
um and thank you so much esther just
tell dave i said hi i will
you guys love each other and uh good
evening and good night and farewell
thanks for listening to bloodbath you
guys don't forget to like this video
subscribe to this channel
go to sleepoverbyester.com for my stuff
my tie-dye is launching what else um
i think that's it thanks bobby oh it's
fun thanks guys we'll see you next time
oh yeah thanks you guys thanks bobby
[Music]
you